Luke is with us in Bellevue Nebraska hey
Luke how are you hey good how about you
Dave
better than I was welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show what's up hey I had a
question
I read your Total Money Makeover book
I'm working my way through one of your
recommended books The Millionaire Next
Door one and I've had a question about
my car loan actually so I was dumb and
brought a brand-new car last summer and
I got one of those 0% interest loans so
I've worked my balance of that loan down
maybe about halfway or so good about 11
or 12 good but I was thinking about
saving up for a house and just get my
emergency fund started more just make it
larger I guess how much is on your
mother's refund um so far I have about
4000 4500 okay and the way this loan
this loan is time weird it's like I've
been paying extra on it
mm-hmm it says my knickers due date
isn't until like November 2018 um so I
don't like I haven't been paying at the
last couple months I've just been
putting that in my savings and said
Czar's gonna ask you know if you think
that's I should keep doing that or if I
should just kill bill to pay that off as
close as I can or not really changed any
of our suggestions since I wrote the
book the Total Money Makeover mm-hmm and
so based on that what does that book
tell you to do do you remember yeah so
it just wants to say that go ahead and
pay off that it says $7,000 first right
baby snip one pay off all debts except
your home and baby step two next and so
that means you take thirty five hundred
dollars today and apply it out of your
savings to this and then you knock this
car loan out and then you would build
your emergency fund maybe step three of
three to six months of expenses does
that sound familiar
yeah definitely uh henges oh okay so I
do actually have a mortgage for a house
now that's my only other debt I thought
you
in a house well I wanna I I bought this
house a few years ago and I just I just
I'm looking to sell at this spring if I
can save up enough so yeah income um I
make 35 a year okay
well I would want you to be debt-free
with an emergency fund before you move
up in house okay and then does the house
have equity in it not very much I would
probably be lucky if I broke even if I
were sell today okay well then we
probably need to save up a down payment
in addition to your emergency fund and
in addition to being debt-free before
you make your move that does not sound
like you're gonna do all that with the
numbers you gave me by spring but you
might you might by the following spring
mm-hmm but you do whatever you want to
do but that's what we suggest and the
reason we suggest that is it is your
shortest path to being wealthy see the
problem is when you just go buy crap
because you just want to then you're
never gonna be out of debt and you're
always gonna struggle with money and you
know you're always gonna take your
income and give it to the bank and
that's what you're talking about doing
so you just gotta decide what you're
gonna do you need to make a decision you
know are you going to get control and
work a system that works or are you just
gonna buy crap that you want to buy
whatever you want to buy it hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]